so i'm new to the daily wire what is the
best piece of advice that you can give
me
stay the hell out of my way weekends in
nashville
what is there to do around here bring
your kids to a playground and
just spend the whole time counting them
to make sure one of them doesn't get
kidnapped if you're looking for good
advice on like a nightlife or something
you probably want to talk to someone who
doesn't have four kids
if you were famous for something else
what would you be famous for something
else i'm not famous in the first place
what about you i good answer
i don't know i really don't know what
i'd be famous for want to circle back
yeah
i'll see i'll circle back if you could
add anyone to mount
rushmore this is a very fun question who
would it be and
why michael knowles no oh i thought i
took the words out of your mouth there
i would add billy mays he just had a
great beard and i'm told that i have a
similar beard to billy mays so you can
just put him on mount rushmore
because he has a good beard and you
think that that would probably come
through on the rocks yeah capitalist
also yeah yeah that's really good that's
good if you could have someone like a
personal assistant
follow you around all the time what
would you have them do
not anything in particular just to have
them obey
me every second of the day that's what i
feel like i need emotionally yeah
well you have like assistance so what do
you have what do you have to do
order me a green juice okay green juices
i like kale aid
kaleid oh my gosh what was your favorite
toy
slash hobby growing up i don't know why
it's a slash we were not allowed to play
with toys
when i was a child um we were told that
it's you know demonic to have toys it's
insensitive this is an insensitive
question
if you could live anywhere in the world
for a year where would it be
definitely nowhere outside the united
states probably somewhere
empty and alone
like north dakota north dakota yeah just
out
flat empty okay if i could live anywhere
in the world it would easily be japan i
had this weird obsession with japan i've
had obsession with japanese people and
the culture
preferably since we didn't say this but
you don't have to pick when samurai
do they let women be samurai soldiers
i'm not sure it doesn't matter it's an
imaginary question when i look into that
before you time travel
you're on death row for a bad tweet from
10 years ago what would your final meal
be
quarter pounder with cheese that's it
yeah i like one more pounders mcdonald's
what do you mean from where there's only
one quarter pounder there's a last meal
you're gonna eat on earth yeah
mcdonald's with a large fry i find the
concept of a last meal to be so strange
like
my last meal would be i would be in
tears sobbing
really and terrified how you're about to
die in 12 hours
you're going to meet the last thing to
eat he's going to be crying i mean it's
first off it's not like they're gonna be
like hanging you they're gonna get a
shot and you're gonna go to sleep
you might as well be thinking you're
going to feel like that wouldn't be much
solace to me right really
because a quarter pounder might be
solace to you what's the best piece of
advice that you've ever received
probably my dad would always say to me
matt stop doing that yeah so it's just a
good piece of advice in general stop
doing it i'm doing that yeah that thing
that you're doing stop
stop it get some help just whatever it
sounds like an order more than advice
just stop
just stop it i'm gonna say pee when you
can not when you have to and it's like
something that
seems like it's small but it really
helps in life it seems so practical yet
so phil
yeah it's so it's it's deep yeah what
celebrity would you be super nervous to
meet
who came up with this question oh my
gosh lamest question um
michael knowles yeah you same
uh yeah me too i'd probably be a little
nervous to meet the queen
the queen definitely the queen why would
you be nervous to meet a celebrity
they're just it's not really a celebrity
so i say
yeah i guess she's not that's a
celebrity right celebrity means a lot of
people are aware of your existence yeah
why should i be nervous to meet you in
that case are celebrities one of your
pet peeves
uh sure yeah we're gonna get out never
ending this
what is something you would have liked
to know at the beginning of your career
um gosh i would have liked to know that
i'd become such an abysmal failure
what fictional character do you wish you
could meet oh gosh you go first because
i feel like i have an answer i don't
have an answer
i don't care about this what come on
spiderman
spiderman oh actually that gave me a
good idea mystique from x-men
i actually want to be her i think that'd
be like the coolest power to have i kind
of changed the question what she's
like girl's like okay sure sounds cool
yeah
what song do you have completely
memorized i have a lot of songs that
arise that's like ridiculous i mean you
could i have everything
i didn't make the question okay um every
song memorized like i mean i could do
the whole sound of music contract i
could do an entire kanye album
so your answer was sound of music whole
whole soundtrack
me too what a coincidence no way i know
the whole thing i i really don't believe
you on that are you being serious no
okay
if a criminal turns himself in should he
get the reward money
you actually thinking about this i'm
just trying to like you know should he
get the reward money for his own
reward a lot deeper who are the real
winners in life right this is a
uh making this way too philosophical
[Music]
i'll circle back give the circle back on
that question okay
does pineapple belong on pizza
absolutely not yeah we're gonna agree on
that
yeah absolutely not and if you have a
problem with that defriend me obama
likes pineapple on his pizza so we know
how that went for america is a hot dog a
sandwich
yes i hate you for saying that i hate
you a little bit two
two pieces of bread uh meat in between
technically one
the fact that they're connected doesn't
matter no it's a gyros a sandwich
uh yeah no a taco's a sandwich because
the taco is more akin
to a hot dog does it have meat yes
you're saying it's taco's the same can i
does it have meat
yes does it have bread yes socratic
method
i just proved it was a sandwich no you
didn't you didn't because you didn't
start with asking me
do all sandwiches have just meat and
bread
all right maybe you could brush up on
your socks buddy if you had to teach
something
what would you teach oh english i love
english
or philosophy i love philosophy i just
taught you socrates i think
so that went well